well this was a short appearance no
longer than three minutes and Connor
Chapman appeared in the custody gray
joggers and um with a shoulder length
hair he only spoke just to confirm his
name his date of birth and his address
and then he nodded when the nine charges
were put to him by the court those
charges including the murder of 26 year
old Ellie Edwards 20 days ago now on
Christmas Eve at the lighthouse in uh in
wallasey the attempted murders as well
two charges of attempted murders there
are other counts including unlawful and
malicious wounding with intent to do
Grievous bodily harm the other charges
also include a possession of firearm
with intent to endanger live possession
of ammunition with intent to endanger
life and handling stolen goods namely a
Mercedes a class it was that Mercedes
A-Class that was incredibly crucial in
the police investigation as they tried
to gather evidence in the days after the
incident those days over Christmas when
Ellie Edwards was with her friends and
family celebrating at the Lighthouse Inn
in wallasey where she was shot just
minutes before Christmas day now uh
Connor Chapman will be remanded in
custody he will remain in the cells and
he will be in court at Liverpool Crown
Court on Monday morning but the police
are still appealing for more information
for people to come forward with further
evidence to help them with their
inquiries to what happened 20 days ago
now Ellie Edwards a beautician a 26 year
old much loved in the community her
family said that she was incredibly
special and everyone knew how special
she was her sister Lucy saying that she
was her best friend her sidekick her
partner in crime and the loss was felt
by many across Wallace Village we saw
members of the family paying tribute to
Ellie as they came and laid flowers at
the scene where she was shot but the man
that police believe was her murderer
Connor Chapman a 22 year old has been
remanded in custody and he will face
Liverpool Crown Court on Monday morning